[Music]
the government
says it won't bring in official vaccine
passports but that's not stopping
businesses and organizations from
creating their own what does this mean
for those who don't
want to get vaccinated in particular
what does it mean
for our ethnic communities who we know
are
much more vaccine hesitant i'm joined by
trevor phillips times columnist former
chair
of the equalities commission and
itinerant writer for the spectator
and rod little a spectator columnist
welcome
to you both rod you wrote about
vaccine passports this week i still
wasn't sure in the end if you were for
or against them
no i'm not sure either to be honest what
i was talking about i read that i read
that right then
do you got it right andrew um i i i was
looking at what the government was
trying to do
and why they had moved away in in the
last couple of weeks from the idea of a
mandatory uh
vaccine passport and it occurred to me
that
uh it was going to be in trouble uh
simply through through grounds of
discrimination that we would be in a
position where
large quantities of of our british
uh black ethnic minority people
are reluctant to have the vaccine and
that would see them excluded from a
whole manner of things
such as cinnamon such as possibly
transport such as restaurants such as
pubs and so on
and i think the government thought it
would be rather better if if business
took the brunt
for that particular uh uh problem rather
than themselves
that was my worry and you raised that
about alabama in the segregation
south before the civil rights in the 60s
and uh but i wonder if that's a is that
a fair comparison
i mean if i if i'm a bus driver in
montgomery alabama
i don't like you on to my bus because
you're black
there's nothing you can do about the
color of your skin
if i'm a restaurant owner i'm not
letting you in whatever your color
because you haven't got a vaccine
passport you can change that
no sure one sure sure andrew and
i was being a little bit facetious uh
but nonetheless
i got that bit too right
i i i there are many in
uh the black and ethnic minority
community you would you would say that
it amounts to pretty much the same thing
and would argue
strongly that the reason for lack of
take-up but i'm sure trevor knows more
about this than i do
that one of the reasons for the lack of
take-up is because and this has been
quoted in the united states on
vaccination programs before now
uh uh historic injustice at the hands of
the health service for black and white
and minority people
so in in the end the chap on the bus
it's it's effectively the same if not
quite as brutal
okay trevor what do you make of this
well
i i read rod's piece and one thing you
can say about
rod's journalism is never knowingly
undercooked
um i think he's taken it to
wild places but there is a basic and an
important point that he raises
here um i think the answer if you're
asking specifically
about the issue of uh what rod describes
mandatory vaccine passports well there
are
two
elements that mandatory no i don't think
so
i think that gets us into very difficult
territory
how do you police it how you qualify all
that stuff
but that's seen passports that
demonstrate that you've had it in the
same way as you do
for yellow fever if you're going to
certain countries and so on i don't see
any problem with that
at all i think actually that would be to
everybody's advantage and today we can
do that pretty simply
by putting an apple on your phone so i'm
i'm completely up for that and i don't
really see that there's any
uh necessary probability of
um uh discrimination in that i think
that there's a bigger problem behind
this which is that
if i can put it bluntly neither the
government or anybody else
really knows what they're talking about
on this
and we're hearing a lot about we know
that there is
vector reluctant well what we've got is
some opinion
polls that tell us that but we don't
know that
actually people from minorities are
taking it up in
uh less frequently than the others i've
had my own vaccine by the way given to
me by
a chinese nurse who really made me feel
she said she said to her mate i don't
check this guy because i don't think
he's
old enough to have it so it made me feel
rather good about it and i suspect
that's going on all around
the health service so you have to i
think that there's a lot of numbers
if you look at the nhs you paid the
chinese nurse for the vaccine i can see
not at all she was lovely
i think there's a lot of knowledge being
taught there's a lot of nonsense being
taught so for example
it's routinely said that ethnic
minorities are more likely to die if you
look at the ons
data week by week from april
last year the the the split between
uh white and non-white has been 86
14 uh 86 14
steadily every single week and as you
will know that is the split in the
population
as a whole now it may be that some
minority groups
are uh dying a greater rate but that's
probably balanced by
those who are less likely to die it may
also be
that minorities are more likely to
become infected but because they have
a younger egg profile less likely to die
the problem is we do not know if i can
point the finger at
government they have been absolutely
scandalously
i mean scandalously lacks in trying to
understand the dynamics of this issue
and they have got many things absolutely
wrong on this question
i i take issue with one thing that
trevor says there which is
the lack of data on black and ethnic
minorities taking up the vaccine
there is quite a bit of data it's
sporadic i quote a couple in the piece i
was writing one is from i think north
north staffordshire
where uh and i think this was largely
bangladeshi
uh uh uh patients to gp surgeries were
ten times less likely
to take up the vaccine that were their
uh white neighbors
uh and there's there was a similar study
i think the government's own figures
uh have also suggested that amongst
african
and uh uh uh british caribbean people
it's the take-up is somewhere in the
region of 50 as opposed to
round about just over 80 for for
for white people so i think there is a
difference there but but but i think
underneath that difference
i i i don't think it's as simple as uh
i think socioeconomics come into it uh
in some cases
in some parts of the of our muslim
community i was talking to mohammed
abbasi
the leader of the uh association of
british muslims today
and the various muslim groups have done
an enormous amount to make sure
that the muslim community is taking up
their vaccine but they're
there's still some worry in some parts
particularly amongst bangladeshis
that the vaccine might have some
contaminatory pig stuff in it
something like that it's there's still
that slight resistance there
so there's loads and loads of different
reasons why and i think most of them are
socioeconomic
minority people may not be taking up
them let's
trevor no let's see if we can
re-establish uh contact with trevor and
we'll get
get back to him um he does seem to have
frozen rod let me come back to
to you just for a second so it seems
that
i think you and trevor both agree that
the there shouldn't be mandatory
sort of government endorsed passports uh
vaccine passports
but what about the private sector
putting aside you your sort of alabama
uh analogy i see trevor's back with us
i'll come to him in a minute
let me finish this question i mean for
example suppose
we hope it's maybe a long shot we might
this summer be able to do our famous
spectator summer party now
you know it well it's usually in a
steamy july night
people are crammed in in a they're
outdoors but it's
pretty crammed in there's not much
social distancing
if we were to say to people you're
welcome to come to
our summer party we're managing to do it
this year
but you have to have a vaccine passport
what would be wrong with that
i don't see that anything would be wrong
with that i'm with trevor on that
the the problem is how it's perceived
and there will be people who try to whip
up the cause of discrimination
uh and they will say that it is that
that is it's simply discriminating
firstly in favor of the affluent because
we know as well
the affluent and the elderly are the two
two trenches of the population who are
most likely to take up the vaccine
so that wouldn't particularly hurt the
spectator summer party
as it's comprised largely of the
affluent of the elderly
oh it's full of young folks it's a
multivital event too
yes you're quite right uh but i i think
uh i think in the i think in the broader
world
some people will find a problem with
that okay let me go back to trevor i'm
delighted we've established
contact again you wanted to reply there
uh
to to rod particularly on on the data
let's come back to that
and tell us what we know let me say i
i probably think i think there is some
thing going on but the problem is
we do not know um by the way on the
question you've just been discussing
the truth of the matter is why are you
going to pay any attention to any idiot
who thinks that the possibility of
discrimination
is a bigger deal than the fact that
black people might actually die from
this thing i mean
frankly i don't think we need to be
bothered with those people our problem
the problem we've got at the moment is
that there are lots of things we do not
actually
know to be true we need the data for
this
reason to understand what it is that is
going wrong
i do not believe that for example the
problem is
language proficiency fewer than two
percent of people in this country cannot
read
or understand english well enough to
understand the messages that are coming
for
forward nor do i think there is some
craziness about what's going on in
internet we can't
one day be complaining about digital
exclusion of minorities
and then say they're not turning up
because they're all busy on twitter
take imbibing the conspiracy theories
that's all nonsense i think there are
probably two or three things we need to
look at
first of all historic mistrust of
authority i think rod's got that right
secondly i think we need to look at
where vaccinations taking place
in the united states they've shown in
massachusetts
that on average uh vaccination centers
white people are twice as likely to live
within a mile of a vaccination center as
black people and that's part of the
example
and the third thing which nobody wants
to talk about but is a real thing
is that we need to think about
people who may be undocumented and who
are not coming forward because what they
believe
is any contact with the authorities of
this kind
will turn the eye of sauron the
immigration authorities on them
and that actually they may get a jab but
the next week they'll be out of the
country and that's the thing that we've
got to try and deal with
give those people confidence that the
system isn't going to lead
to them being targeted by immigration
authorities
i'm interested trevor uh that you say
that the figures are not as clear-cut as
some of the coverage
has been that we we need to be careful
in talking about
the the uh the uptake uh being that
different
from the rest of the population well the
narrative is
the narrative has overcome any regard
for data
and as you know andrew my businesses now
data scientists
and you i can't tell you how furious i i
mean to take
roger uh rod's point i understand why he
believes that
but i can tell you for certain we'll
publish data we'll publish a paper on
this probably in the next three or four
weeks
there is one large local authority we've
run we've run the records of about a
million patients
and what we know is that there are about
a half a million
records in that authority which has a
couple of million people in it
which have no ethnicity data on them so
the data on which the nhs is working
it has a huge margin of error there's
loads of things we do not know
but people are asserting confidently
and unfortunately that will probably
mean that we make we're probably making
mistakes
taking the wrong steps and ignoring for
example very small groups
who need some special treatment i said
that's it right i'll give you a final
word on this
i think the fascinating thing is uh the
the take-up of the vaccine in europe it
seems to me
almost certain that one of the reasons
for the very high take-up in
in the uk is the fact that it's a bit of
patriotism in there
there's a bit of good news story that we
were developing the vaccine
and have done better than the rest of
europe in getting it out and i think
that's
rather swung more people than were
expected behind the vaccine
but it's it's also fascinating to look
at the the various
the various reasons in europe
particularly amongst countries which
suffered under
totalitarian governments uh the visigrad
countries where take-up is very low
east germany where take-up is a lot
lower than it is in west germany
but germany again as another as another
example they had a
a a much hated vaccination program from
1874
compulsory for smallpox and it did
wonders it eradicated smallpox from
germany
but it was very unpopular particularly
under the wine weimar government
but because of the side effects and some
children dying in schools as a
consequence of this
it was all carried out in schools so
there's a long historical memory
of compulsory vaccination and a big
government bearing down upon people
and that's one reason why they take up
so low another reason i think could be
the
the obverse to what i was saying about
britain that
in europe they have mishandled the
vaccine
appallingly it has been slow
uh sluggish under the eu and i suspect
that that has its effect
upon what people think about the vaccine
in the end
it's a it's a fascinating topic i think
rod's got a really important point there
we talk about minorities and we
constantly are thinking about people of
color
let's bear in mind we have at least
nearly a million
people from poland uh in this country
plus from other
east european countries many of whom
have parents and grandparents who lived
under
authoritarian regimes who frankly could
not be trusted
and it's not surprising if some of that
if you like
memory would discourage them from
trusting any authority even in this
country
that says oh come don't worry we're
going to look after you because frankly
behind the iron curtain for the best
part of 70 years
we're going to look after you meant you
weren't coming back home
gentlemen we'll leave it there thank you
for joining me on spectator tv
rod and trevor there
[Music]
you